[Musique]
mes amis je viens de rentrer chez vous
sans avoir pu pour frapper à la porte
alors je crois qu'il est bon de me
présenter d'abord de vous dire un
certain nombre de choses et de réfuter
un certain nombre d'arguments qui devait
présenter quelques fois contre moi je ne
suis pas un candidat doux rêveur j'ai 45
ans travaille agronomique sur le terrain
où 45 ans de travail d'enseignement
surtout à l'institut national
agronomique de paris donc dire que je
suis un candidat pas sérieux c'est tout
de même s'avancer un peu vite quand on
va étudier les problèmes au village avec
les paysans avec les agriculteurs on le
doit être sérieux
par ailleurs si je n'étais pas sérieux
est-ce que j'aurais été choisi par plus
de 50 associations
représentant plus de cent mille
adhérents répartis à travers la france
est ce que si je ne devais pas sérieux
je renonce j'aurais été présentée par
176 signature sans compter celles qui
sont arrivés en retard dans 80 plus de
80 maires de communes rurales de petites
communes qui sont tous les jours en
contact avec le problème de la terre
dont 65 agriculteurs dont 15 médecins
des notaires des commerçants et autres
notabilités je représente ici un
programme écologique un mouvement
écologique est d'abord ce mot nouveau
pour beaucoup d'entre vous l'écologie
qu'est ce que c'est ce n'est pas un mot
gadget qui a inventé pour les besoins de
cette campagne c'est un mot créé en 1866
par le biologiste allemand ernst haeckel
qui étudie les rapports entre les êtres
vivants et les milieux où ils vivent
aujourd'hui je viens revenir en france
pour étudier avec vous les problèmes
très graves qui se pose après avoir
beaucoup étudier les problèmes de la
faim dans le monde dans le tiers monde
j'estime que aujourd'hui il est temps de
s'occuper des problèmes de nos pays mais
nous les écologistes
on nous accuse d'être des prophètes de
malheur et d' annoncer l'apocalypse
le kop l'apocalypse nous n'annonçons pas
elle est là parmi nous elle se trouve
dans les nuages de pollution qui nous
domine dans les eaux d'égout qui sont
que sont devenus nos rivières nos
estuaires et nolito romarin on espérait
tirer de ces eaux de la mer des
ressources
importantes on pensait que ce sera le
grenier de l'humanité de demain coc
estuaire ses plateaux continentaux se
sont aujourd'hui nos poubelles là où on
jette tous nos détritus on a dit que
j'étais un vieux professeur qui se
baladait à vélo mais oui le 16 mars si
j'étais avec mes amis de la terre de la
porte d'orléans à la concorde pour
montrer que paris pourrait être au moins
pour un jour et dans quelques rues le
domaine de ces instruments de transport
à deux roues qui ne pollue pas
on a dit que j'étais donc un fantaisiste
je crois que les vingt livres que j'ai
écrits la diffusion qu'ils ont eue haute
beaucoup de poids à de tels arguments je
me présente ici comme un candidat propre
à tous les sens du terme puisque nous
sommes pour la propreté de l'air et de
l'eau et parce que tous les comptes
d'élection seront présentés au public
seront officielles les un conte l'heure
le coût de leur campagne en millions de
francs lourd nous allons les compter
avec un tout petit nombre 2 millions de
froch léger candidat propre qui respecte
les murs qui sait que le papier est rare
comme l'énergie et qui par conséquent ne
va pas couvrir nos murs d'affiche et
vous ne verrez pas ma tête sur les murs
de nos villes d'abord lorsque nous
n'avons pas d'argent ensuite parce que
je n'ai pas envie de voir ma tête sur
tous les murs de la ville à quoi ça sert
quels arguments ça apporte de montrer sa
binette sur tous les murs de la ville
c'est une grosse une grossière plaisante
un candidat pauvres je voulais dit c'est
pour cela que nous sommes amarré au port
de l'alma à côté du pont de l'alma sur
un bateau mouche
étaient gracieusement mis à notre
disposition par un ami de
l'environnement qui s'inquiète notamment
de voir notre dame assailli par les
autos à cause d'un projet de voie
express rive gauche
nous serons les seuls à parler d'un
projet global d'avenir les seuls à
regarder en face les menaces de notre
expansion illimitée le pillage du
tiers-monde amène un gaspillage il oui
de nos matières premières la france
consommait 5 millions de tonnes de
pétrole en 1939 la france consomme et
120 millions de tonnes de pétrole en
1973 une telle expansion illimité ne
peut pas se poursuivre ceux qui vous
disent le contraire sont des
inconscients ou des menteurs nous
n'aurons plus les moyens d'acheter des
telles quantités notre économie que l'on
dit de plus en plus indépendante depuis
trente ans notre depuis quinze ans
surtout notre économie depuis quinze ans
est de plus en plus dépendantes la
france a perdu son indépendance
économique puisque toute son économie
dépend d'une forme d'énergie importés
qui va devenir de plus en plus coûteuses
ces matières premières que l'étirement
nous fournissait presque gratuitement
c'était le pillage du tiers-monde
pillage de matières premières sous payés
ce qui nous permettait de gaspiller ces
matières premières d'une façon
inconsidérée alors il va falloir cesser
ces problèmes de pillage cesser ses
formes de gaspillage qui aboutissent à
des choses invraisemblables aux états
unis sont rejetées chaque année 48
milliard de boîtes de conserve vides 65
milliards d'emballages en métal et en
plastique et il y a neuf ans en 1965 le
coût d'enlèvement de tous ces détritus
s'élever à 15 milliards de francs lourd
notre population ne peut augmenter
indéfiniment et vous savez ce qui va se
passer eh bien nous allons bientôt
manquer de l'eau et c'est pourquoi je
bois devant vous un verre d'eau
précieuse puisque avant la fin du siècle
si nous continuons un tel débordement
elle manquera à lundi je vous dis au
revoir et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis
[Musique]